joining us now from Washington are two
House members who have seen these
classified documents Raul Labrador of
Idaho and Andy Biggs of Arizona we're
also joined by Fox News contributor
Byron York who has been extensively
covering the Russia probe and this
dossier issue gentlemen it's great to
see you tonight congressman Labrador I
want to start with you I started getting
calls I'm here on the west coast but I
started getting calls about this at
about I don't know six thirty in the
morning Pacific time by congressman who
started to read this report and they
didn't reveal anything they weren't
supposed to but they said Laura whatever
you do that people have to know what is
in this this has to get Declassified
tell us how we can be classify it and
whatever you can tell us about what's
inside great Laura thanks for having me
on your show this is so important and
and it's important for your viewers to
know that the house has the authority to
release this information we don't have
to declassify it house rule 10 and this
is something that I think we're going to
talk about a lot over the next few weeks
house rule 10 allows the Select
Committee to release the information
based on the public interest if they
believe that the information is
important enough to the public that is a
vital importance to the public they can
release it so all we need to do is have
a vote from the house and the house
select committee can do that and I think
we need to do that immediately in the
next week or so I believe that the
American people need to see everything
that is in this document I cannot tell
you
congressman Biggs can't tell you either
about what we read today but people will
be shocked when they see this
information
congressman Biggs before we get to byron
and we are going to hit on this
immigration debate and the government
shutdown and the Labradors legislation
all that would Byron and you guys but on
this issue of the release of this report
is there any national security concern
about releasing this document that you
can see now you've read it anything that
Paul Ryan could point to to avoid a
move to declassify were a bureaucratic
administrative move to release its
contents I don't think so
I saw nothing in there that releasing it
to the public would it have any negative
effect on our national interest in fact
I think it's just the opposite I think
the national interest is harmed by
keeping it a secret from the public I
think we have to be transparent we have
to get this out there it is so vital so
important and I think Americans are
going to be as outraged as I know Raul
and I are and and many of my colleagues
who've read this it has to get out and I
don't believe you can hide behind the
shield of national security interests
because because the problem is just
flipped on its head and you'll notice it
was Democrats in that committee that
don't want it released not one release
it yeah alright Byron Byron I want to go
to you on this
I heard again four people congressman
this morning and people very high up in
the Justice Department and the FBI could
very well lose their jobs if this report
goes public do you believe that given
what we've heard from Glenn Simpson is
the head of fusion GPS he said he's
trying to like poopoo the idea that you
know they really moved on the dossier
with the you know although the old
administration how explosive could this
be well it'd be pretty darned explosive
we you and I are the two people here who
haven't actually seen the document but
we've been hearing about this for quite
a long while what's been interesting is
the investigators in the house
have been kind of in a box for months
they were learning things of great
public interest but it was classified
and they couldn't tell the public and
the institution that had the authority
to declassify at the Justice Department
was the institution they were
investigating I mean it was just kind of
a trap and I think what we saw today was
a kind of a brilliant effort to bust out
of that which is to use a maneuver to
create a summary of their work and allow
all members of the House to see it so it
wasn't just a small group of 13 people
on the Republicans on the House
Intelligence Committee all of a sudden
it was any
in the house could go down and take a
look at this and we've been hearing them
coming out and saying wow this is really
really big and that is increasing the
momentum to try this parliamentary
maneuver that represented a Labrador and
others have been talking about and they
also at the same time I guess
congressman Labrador the Democrats were
okay with releasing the Glenn Simpson
testimony correct they were okay with
that we're gonna play a snippet of that
for our viewers it's important for them
to see what the founder of that Fusion
GPS said let's watch oh we don't oh I'm
sorry it's a full screen sorry about
that guys
he was asked did the FBI ever reach out
to you or Fusion GPS in relation to the
matters that mr. Steele informed them
upon he said no you've never heard from
anyone inside the US government in
relation to those matters either the FBI
or the Department of Justice answer well
after the election I mean during the
election no well what did you hear after
and from home and when I was asked to
provide some information to the Justice
Department questioned by whom and when
it was by a prosecutor named Bruce or
who was following up
did mr. Oher reach out to you or how did
that check out yeah so in other words
Nelly or who works for effusion GPS
Bruce or ended up being the source of of
that the questions about that dossier
congressman Labrador your reaction to
that well I can't speak about the
specific facts because I saw this memo
today I have to be very careful what I
say about the the facts that happened
here but what's interesting is that this
morning the Democrats decided to vote
against releasing this memo that's
number one number two when I was in the
in the room and I've heard from other
members of Congress when they were in
the room there were no Democrats who
actually came down to look at this memo
so they were so interested in the Russia
collusion story until their Russia
collusion story actually started started
unraveling so now that we have some
information that is being provided to
every member of the house they are
unwilling to release it or to even look
at it I think what what the American
people will find
is that who think they're gonna be
shocked by this memo I invite everybody
to use the hashtag release the memo I
hope all of your viewers start with the
release of memo because we need to push
our house leadership to do this and I
believe that they want to do this I hope
that they do and that they stand with
the American people and the congressman
Biggs way at a time we could do an hour
on this are people gonna lose their jobs
one that this is going to get released
are people going to lose their jobs it
probably ought to probably ought to I'm
just say I'm shocked that some have it
already
all right gentlemen fascinating we
didn't have time to get into the
immigration bill of Labrador that the
president supports and the White House
supports but we really appreciate the
analysis and guys get this